employers are going to be paying you
more cash that's right if your boss
ain't paying you more money in 2022 you
need a new job a new job employers are
expected to pay more in salaries and
bonuses to retain talent in 2022 if
you're talented your boss needs to fork
over the cash inflation end wages over
the last decade inflation has lingered
between one and two percent over the
last decade but now it is at nearly
seven percent while pay raises have
increased between two and three percent
during the same time period but when you
have inflation now at nearly seven
percent obviously only a two or three
percent pay raise ain't getting the job
done and so there's a brand new survey
out of how many companies are actually
increasing their wages 51 percent of hr
leaders in the us said their
organization expects average merit
increases of more than 5 percent
according to grant thornton 68 said
their company already increased the
number of employees eligible to receive
a cash bonus and that was all due to
polling 551 senior u.s hr leaders of
companies with at least 500 employees
now in november remember this was all
done in august in november a couple
months ago those who switched jobs saw
the 12-month moving average wage gains
of 4.3 percent those who stayed in their
current position saw gains of 3.2
percent we are not mathematicians we are
not the second coming of einstein but we
do know how to read these numbers which
means that if you switch jobs your pay
goes up if you stay in your job your pay
does not go up as fast and so tim glowa
a principal at grant thornton said wages
are in many cases kind of the table
stakes a situation that organizations
have to get right in order to attract
and retain people and then he went on to
say this isn't just an hr problem
anymore it's a c-suite problem we're
seeing more organizations needing to
work together as a leadership team to
figure out what they can do to retain
talent but of course employees are
saying hey tim i appreciate you i
appreciate you telling them they gotta
pay us they gotta help us secure the bag
for us to stay at our jobs our job you
want me to work for you pay me more
money but salary is not the only thing
that employees care about 51 percent
would give up a 10 to 20 salary increase
for more flexibility in when and where
they work the people want freedom they
don't want to just get paid and that is
according to 1500 full-time u.s
employees i don't know if that's
necessarily true across the entire
united states that people would give up
20 salary increase for a little bit more
freedom but 51 said they would which is
about half which means that 49
say nah dog pay me more cash i'll need
that freedom you can pay me to be here
whenever you want do we think that
people are gonna get paid more a five
percent raise according to the hr teams
doesn't even keep up with inflation
right now should people be going in and
telling uh their hr teams their bosses i
need a seven eight nine ten percent
raise or i gotta go find a new job
there's ten and a half million jobs out
there and somebody wants my skills if
you want me to stay here
pay me more
yes yeah if you're getting paid
if you are not getting paid seven
percent more than you got paid last year
you are getting paid less this year than
you did last year simply put you're
losing perching power at a historic rate
40-year high for inflation uh you should
absolutely do absolutely do that and i
think you have to tee to the line
between
basically implying that you want to make
more money at that job and not hinting
at hey if i don't make more money i'm
going to leave this job because you
don't want to be like basically
necessarily fired or looked down upon in
the workplace for wanting more money but
yeah go go get your bag go get your
money yeah i also think it uh it depends
because people that are in their current
situation i think it's much harder to
uh not necessarily ask for a raise like
that's very kind of vanilla you go in
and you say hey
it's very clear you go and you say hey
look inflation's this much i'm doing a
good job i'd like to make x amount more
and maybe you get it maybe you don't who
really knows i think it depends on the
certain circumstance but i think what
we're going to see is wages are going to
start to drastically increase and have
been increasing for people finding new
jobs and right and that's just kind of
what it is when it comes to employers
looking to hire good people because the
workforce uh the labor market is so
tight right now when you go out and
you're looking for a new job they have
to offer you these benefits otherwise
you're not gonna take it you're gonna go
work somewhere else and those benefits
can include financial compensation but
they can also include other things like
the ability to work remote or kind of uh
different perks that come with the job
whether it's health insurance or
retirement benefits or other things so i
think right now the average employee in
the united states kind of looking for
work has more strength than ever before
when it comes to not only salary but
other benefits because so many of these
companies are looking to hire good
people immediately and i think that's
what we're going to start seeing in the
data when it comes to wages also go ask
for a raise and when you go ask for a
raise
basically explain to them what you made
last year what you make this year what
the inflation numbers are and what
you've done over the last year to kind
of prove your worth and if you think you
are worth more than you were last year
to the company and then also find some
comps um to other jobs that are similar
to yours and what those people get paid
and if you're getting paid under that
explain that and explain that these
people at other companies are getting
paid more than you for similar work um
and then if they still don't give you a
raise and you want to leave go find a
job that's giving you more money do you
worry at all that uh if you go ask for a
raise and they say no that uh like you
ruin your relationship or is it like you
when you go ask for the raise and say
like hey look i can go leave my job and
get a raise somewhere else that you
actually have to be willing to leave
yeah yeah i mean if you threaten to
leave you have to be willing to leave
yeah i think that like that's one of the
the big pitfalls is when people go and
ask and they're like oh but i can leave
like if they're like okay then leave and
you don't leave then like they own you
forever yeah right
like that's the first world negotiation
forever no that's personal negotiation
if you say something and somebody calls
your bluff and you get them
you basically were bluffing
you got no negotiating power ever again
because the next time you ask for a
raise they're going to be like
we can just tell them
go ahead go ahead leave we dare you we
triple dog dare you they know you're not
going to leave so again you got to be
careful in the negotiation or in the ask
you can say hey look i've been doing a
lot more plus there's inflation plus
there's this right i really like to stay
here i like who i work with i like what
i do i enjoy working for you help me
help you yeah can
you know what what is the path second
thing that i always tell people is when
you go to ask for a raise don't ask for
it immediately right in in the sense of
like i need to raise right now no
instead we could say is listen i know
you guys have planning purposes and then
you have budgeting etc what is the path
to me getting the raise right
could is it possible for me to get the
raise starting in q2 right and give them
kind of a 90 day or at this point maybe
75 day kind of lead time to actually get
the budget in place and be in a position
where they're able to actually go ahead
uh and uh and do that
it depends but that that's all the type
of stuff that i think ends up being
worth the uh worth of conversation at
least with a uh with somebody like that
right it won't burn a bridge necessarily
i think most people are reasonable in
when you ask for something and
there's kind of a disconnect on what
they can pay you or what they want to
pay you versus what you want to receive
as compensation for your job there's
definitely a disconnect there but it's
not going to burn a bridge if you if you
do it politely in a manner that you can
show proof as to why you want it um and
if they still don't give it to you and
you leave basically explaining them and
be like look i asked for a raise i think
i'm worth this you said no so i'm gonna
today's my last day